made me feel like I'm just eating cold
vomit I've tried a little bit of baby
food
I feel like applesauce is pretty much
baby food I've consumed baby food
secondhand as my baby vomited it into my
mouth oh my goodness I thought baby food
in April because I wanted to eat most of
it grosses me out and then I feel really
guilty about giving it to my kids summer
vegetable delight is a wonderful name
it looks like my cat's vomits smells
like cornbread is that what you call it
oh my god that's all no it's bad I think
it tastes like dog food is it dog food I
taste like squash or zucchini or
something it tastes like smash that
piece in preservatives and maybe there's
carrot in it no not for me
it's super creamy shiny it looks like a
banana color and the texture and
consistency are very pudding like it's
really sweet surprisingly sweet oh my
god that's just terrible I love it
I would eat this as an adult it's
creeping me out that I'm eating baby
food but like I guess it's that's good
I've never eaten sweet potato with
chicken before it anything
is that way come whoa there's some spots
wondering if they put like cinnamon or
nutmeg inside of something to spice it
up
I don't want babies are into spice I
don't know what they do to it to make it
so disgusting cuz like just a sweet
potato tastes better than this this
tastes like straight-up squash and
therefore I don't want to eat any more
cuz there's chicken in there and I can't
taste it it's freaking me out this
definitely looks like traditional baby
food it looks like a giant booger maybe
this is the reason why kids don't like
green foods because they're introduced
in this manner Oh God
the green beans are already kind of like
a soggy vegetable and this is just like
to the extreme right this way not a fan
of this oh it's not a fan of you either
okay you can have it
[Music]
it was more bland than I thought it
would be maybe this is a reason why kids
are such picky eaters because their
heads and bland disgusting foods it's
just like so tasteless but at the same
time disgusting it's really confusing
just a tiny bit of hot sauce and some of
those wouldn't make all the difference
in the world he couldn't swallow it I
couldn't I could not swallow it I don't
need as much as him I did a big spoonful
[Music]